but let's go something goes where's
Giffords gameplay history
[Laughter]
I cheered oh banana cheered two best
players on your team you and Lee oh I
did not see I just saw we can we can
always you know why cuz I we have a
robot thing I don't know my friend has
bronze and private matches speaking of
no I want to I just wanted to clarify I
have to kiss pika shoes shoes and we
gotta get I thought Steve I thought
Steve a was gonna win in corn
knock them out I believed in DC and Koch
didn't because I said yeah I said loser
has to get tattoo of the other person
and Pikachu is afraid to do it and then
that was two minutes not two minutes
later I was like goddamn I'm glad Peaks
did you donate cuz I just wondering when
I worked if we're gonna see it did I
donated it again oh so don't you has to
keep donating all night individual
person donate it should I think DC can
beat lesser the question is do you does
anybody think was there to be DC because
he's gonna get [ __ ] up yeah it doesn't
matter how [ __ ] biggie is I can't
prove that already John McCain see that
[ __ ] like that track is gonna lose his
followers that's gonna lose us can you
shoot Griffin in the face thank you God
don't don't come crying to me about
killing [ __ ] cuz you know damn
well you know I'll get a me out I'm
gonna be tough on this [ __ ]
leaderboard oh [ __ ] homie I'm using that
goddamn grenade launcher forgot I gotta
make you a mod since Iman I'll do it
later
oh come on
I swear from
no they are you picked up that heavy I
saw you I'll do it every time I'm down
raucous do whatever time that swing
piece of [ __ ] got it anyway grab at the
moment why do I keep getting real I
haven't seen it because I'm unlucky
[ __ ] yep that's me what's the what's
the team's
okay our team is Kok OB Craig and me
other teams hi watch there's no way Oh
me and you took no damage hi buddy oh
wait that didn't kill you I swear it
[Laughter]
stopped just standing here come with me
yeah come with them into rigs like there
are people that are whoa I feel like the
team's might be a little thank God
Pikachu's on your team cuz I've killed
him like six times already
oh well it's true you just died again oh
me oh me stop it with the grenade this
is not fair teams is it four against
three as for it's four against four but
it seems like four against three to be
honest oh it's unreal Griffin
unreal meskhi how the hell this United
Johan buddy looking living the dream
bread yeah
dude there's like four dead here you
didn't see anyone this had my skis was
so soothing sorry about our trade war
Maggie but Craig that start I'm just
saying I'm just saying yes
I just want meskhi to know it's not us
like who the [ __ ] is it ten renamed
effect
well it's us as a country but not us as
individually I don't know what you're
talking to I individually send about
fifty percent tariffs on maple syrup
alone but that isn't counts as I'm just
not buying indeed Griffin the Everett or
Canada somebody even though hit the rock
yeah I'm going to Winnipeg hey he's on
our team
whoo yeah you're fine you're fine
goddamn it this is no useless super that
I have changed the hell are you doing
right now
get over here
run past three different people you ran
past a lot of people I know I was well
you guys are all moving around each
other I was trying to get away
[Laughter]
my does not submit any more vigilant
swing swing is goddamn vigils Wilson and
[ __ ] graviton yeah they're great
yeah especially when you get the [ __ ]
catalyst for it it's goddamn laser beam
now a fully automatic look out of there
a full beam bullets damn it
I've got rocket [ __ ] rockets yes
slick Wilfred Griffin rear face first at
this clash until 75 what's the that's us
one mr. Liguori no mr. Bob like arena
you he's out of ten
I got double right you're kidding me
well there's everybody right here
you can hear them I do private [ __ ]
running around dancing on people dodging
bullets I don't what are you the one
damn [ __ ] Neil back here that's okay
did I die
no well I'm playing around
damn
ah
unreal there can only be so back
handcannon Shambo and you're telling me
I love you I know you you sign my planes
[Laughter]
how much would you charge for that code
I change signs you charge for no no well
they got right now that's it bro the
turning point mask you joined the party
[Laughter]
hey hey this man right here Oh freakin
green boy let's go hold me like five
times already now hey no get back here
I didn't do any punchout behind it do
planking who's that night I'm getting
hot [ __ ] come on Griffin where did those
tethers fry man hide shirt it's all
right
how are you still alive
wait what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah all right guys are you trying there
was a time we would've went [ __ ]
flawless but Craig was on her wallet
Pikachu forgot he forgot to clear his
[ __ ] card and ironically Pikachu his
chat or whatever [ __ ] up the last game
in his chat to switch it up and switch
what do you mean we don't need to switch
it up that was a good game anything
bringing you
I just I think there's definitely
limitations
I mean having one arm that's what you
you can't do a you can't do a one or you
know you have to get them on one is one
arm Oh your Amarra or something Craig
yeah Bolger you want to join this send
me not in orbit though anything I'm
flying you dr. dog feature you realize
you're the only person that went
negative that last game Pikachu's he's
like one of the Transformers that's like
the janitorial staff
[Laughter]
yeah you got left behind you gonna keep
it going forever man yeah I did this in
short because I don't think we've ever
done this for price
we've ever done this man [ __ ] is my
cellphone oh well what's your call time
tomorrow I got a look at this sheet I
think a study gonna change it like I got
a look and see oh it's one of those up
got it you know staff with that I hate
that [ __ ] that means like they don't
know and in another country think of
that yeah
well it's just that that should [ __ ]
scheduling sucks to you and they change
it every three seconds
yeah died Craig he [ __ ] why did you
walk are you talking about I was
shooting him I don't know what you're
talking about
I don't know you're the one who got now
you know it was Griffin had a 1.01 and
he gets you had a point six [ __ ] okay
I'll try goddamn it I was trying to
chase you every [ __ ] radaway how you
is hurt I know you're trying to Jason
and I debated you leave you join
disgraceful
oh Jesus sake insurance whenever folded
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah oh my god I had in my
sight [ __ ] you messy double thing the
[ __ ] yeah not even its vigilance wing
all the way wait wait a second are you
using safer teams helm on a sunbreaker
no as a strike as vassal is he talking
cuz I don't know really nothing needs to
you guys do all the talkin yeah we know
we're sorry Craig talks
too much I'm sorry I am
I'm just trying to know I'd like know
all the actions the same place
hey crystal how can t I don't even want
time to peek at you anymore wearing me
down
oh body yes whoa pre shot right there oh
good good good god be with that after
the fact what the [ __ ] you were dead for
like two minutes
hi I'm terrible now letting the last
game I'm gonna leave in this one Pikachu
is it's [ __ ] princess back Oh
hope you following Pikachu and then just
left them alone
that's how i Griffin all that I said if
you need to chase them and kill them
fine
be careful
what is he using heat up vigilance of
course it's like a [ __ ] laser beam of
bullets thank you not that good I was
blocked by my own they got a gun
whoever shot down that was beautiful oh
my scope was blocking that was
tremendous no can they got heavy Damon
why do scopes have to be so just be like
the defiance the Gasman
have no scope laughs your level tier
left we got a guy parade types coming
what the foot bed controller wasn't that
was stupid in the controller Shirley
what I wait what what
stupid Griffin you can you dig in
yeah masky you die right out here my
hammers after I cleaned your [ __ ]
team Griffin that was my first death
this whole game god they're rolling
together we are not rolling together
that's why to do it oh my god and my ski
let's get it that you said help No blast
your face
I just realized Craig's on my team yeah
unfortunately that's what you have
really well have you noticed that your
team doesn't like do well when we're
winning I'll switch I said we could
switch teams last game and you're like
now keep him that saying guys if we're
gonna push out and like I'm gonna shoot
them don't just sit in a cave and wait
for me to die and then just run out
that's [ __ ] stupid but you look so
beautiful when you're dead yeah Bo I'm
gonna come to wherever you live [ __ ]
down your throat and rip off
next geez Wow a little angry there yeah
it got really vulgar really quick I took
it to a dark place
oh come on
ha ha V he's one shot he's right here
what's that thanks go go got you just
died I killed you come on hide
don't call d ov2 the column you
straight-up hit me through the column
I'm playing like making sure your class
game but I didn't know that's Griffon
them I chilled by the architects [ __ ]
miss thing in this game oh my god how
many of you are there in that cave 28 at
a party oh my god oh my god well she's
just sitting in this area back here I
know I know
yeah he's doing what Griffin says he
likes to [ __ ] think [ __ ] taps me
one time damn it I was head shiny but
you were below me so you didn't see you
didn't see no we just kill his little
dumb ass
that's challenge I'm asked if it gets
rusty bastard kill heavier no eggs
ouch come on boo Bros from here our case
kulak pipes yeah yep yep oh no way no
way they're behind this hammers don't
worry it's just Pikachu you didn't tell
me he was behind me why he just came out
of nowhere I killed him
well you can say grog I don't know the
name for the maps man well I don't even
know it was cold you don't know we don't
know I'm in the basin's like that yes
good game guys well you did better than
me Pikachu I'll give it to you talking
all that [ __ ] can we switch teams now
Pikachu no yes okay worst players from
this mission yeah I did terrible first
thing in the second person gets to pick
two so it's first picking in second to
you give it I'm saying that's how you do
it okay so that's out fear
all right so everybody go to one side oh
my god
okay i'll Achille you can choose
obviously wonderful and what fine fine
Cragen gross word team captains yeah
your team captains yes you guys are the
worst last game alright I'll take what
Netsky yeah might say alright next
he's not gonna choose cold even is my in
there is Mike I was saying okay so I'm
saying like so are we gonna just pick
one after the other or is it going to be
I guess I have to take coke it's either
hyper unreal what do I want one yeah
there we go alright then I'm taking
unreal all right so what take bulgur you
can take now that's it that's it we got
it
let's do it okay
[Laughter]
I don't dude you think I know the math
batter ball yogi says he said it
manifold banner final order radiant
cliffs I don't know what are we time a
Griffin is staying in a hotel room so
and he doesn't have his Elgato so he's
it just his face she's anybody asking is
it Montreal or stream yeah she's up
subscribe Stevie from Pikachu's own
personal stash that's this whole week's
big issue I know let's work together
let's work together work apart now
Pikachu let's let's do it let's work one
button and layin on your team don't need
a team - nice choice Chang a face you're
right that's a good
[Laughter]
and then he's gonna get a chat she's a
didn't take the tattoo bet you get a
Pikachu tattoo I know that's what I'm
saying
nice unreal yep there we go Griffin get
out of cover the marine life I'm not
it's the crucible um
pulse rifle ninja you should know oh how
did you wherever you go
okay let's go in here
I'm gonna die mess is that mask he's on
my team
he's a girl charm
come on dude yes nice thank you why must
you fit what's your cabin around well
they're gonna start throwing each other
under the bus watch guys maybe gray
homies really hurt guys I'm trying to
get those guys over here
wait what kind of my just in a wrong con
is there a right gun Oh who's this
who is it how are they
isn't Griffin Bailey just because they
have an extra hair if you want to come
in here it's a party flanked I miss me
with that gay [ __ ]
Logie words a rocky beach no me miss me
with that dad told me alternate life see
a man from analized power you both alive
oh my gosh kill him come on dre I was so
frustrated cuz he should have been dead
like 10 seconds before that thing got
punched in the face yeah but I dude we
gotta stop we have to stop moving when
he's thinking about tomorrow's got a
weak nature of the beast
yeah hand cannon right who are you guys
you see those letters
I mean you mean the exes you mean the
exes from your death actually just wanna
see gold I hit the skull yeah no you do
know it's on your screen it's an X when
the person died on that little picture
it's a stove it's a stall can anybody
look caught on a mini-map it's an X well
I'm a Mimi madam I'm your heads up under
heads-up display it's a scope you guys
are gonna give I think hype like a brain
aneurysm like it is early I'm gonna lose
my [ __ ] mind
this team is running of the unit we're
spawning like that only run after them
and then we're just [ __ ] dying doing
my one by one by one just gonna sit down
here think get to you guys oh my god
destroyed let's go let's go
there's Pikachu Oh Mike I don't know you
[Music]
I run Thanks oh it should help maybe
that's your response run
yes run I miss Becky I wanted you to
hammer me so much but you're hammering
them instead new Amber's there's a new
super for each class September Oh
oh my god good shotgun yep be real Oh
for super sub class Oh
1h doctor what do you mean every Oh are
they are they getting rid of the ones
they already have in place
no we don't know mad either reworking
the morning oh my god but we know
they're staying we don't know if they're
reworking them oh I'll take I'll take
Laurie arrow any day it's good of my my
are almost gone I stole that kill
somehow but I know that's all good I
don't even know how I'm like tickling
them to death
Pikachu in what world do you think maybe
like one in a hundred all worst grenade
in the history of grenades [ __ ] law
all three of them right there where are
these dudes just running that's our only
option spread out [ __ ] start playing
the Benny Hill music snake differently
shooting if I after the way oh my god
Pikachu you're disgusting God kill him
go thank you that's all we need it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm out of my [ __ ] but
my speaks
even with the ripped down right you got
me a terrible artist soul I soon when I
sue
Oh cooking Oh me why hire to survive
that foolish it's only he survives what
he once a shield on bottom half on top
oh my god no body's still floating
god dammit hey get up almost god I was
[ __ ] absolute there Mitch
[Music]
right that's so hard to find anybody you
guys are killing them so fast you're
using tracker Ken the most Opie shotgun
at the moment yeah I'm flying I'm like
an ad hype those balloons that was
pretty cool Craig point three two point
four five point seven five IC point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]